ready to go back to Derry the first
trailer for it
chapter 2 has arrived and it looks like
writer director Andy mushi Eddy might
just pull it off again though most of
the clip is dedicated to one scene there
are a few small but telling details that
you might have missed spoilers ahead
meet mrs. Kirsch most of the trailer
finds Beverly Marsh returning to her
father's old home the new resident seems
like a nice enough old lady doesn't she
meanwhile Bev is heartened to discover
the old January embers poem that Ben
wrote for her so many decades before but
the atmosphere in the apartment grows
earier by the second especially when
mrs. Kirsch starts verbally tormenting
Beverley I was always daddy's new girl
what about you if you read Stephen
King's massive novel it you'll remember
this moment as one of the creepiest
scenes in the book in the novel mrs.
Kirsch transforms into a yellow tooth
which the trailer doesn't quite show us
what shall become in the movie but we're
already covering our eyes here's another
detail from the trailer that really
stands out the losers Club appears to
have thinned out although the group
still sees young Stanley URIs and Eddy
calves break in a window reflection
there are now only five of them standing
as adults Isiah Mustafa's Mike Hanlon
Bill hader's Ritchie tozer
James McAvoy's Bill den bro Jessica
Chastain's Beverly and Jay Ryan's Ben
Hanscom if you read Kings novel you know
that Stanley URIs never makes it back to
Derry Eddy does join the group for a
second battle against Pennywise but his
fate isn't as fortunate as the rest
however in the book Eddie's death takes
place late in the action perhaps the
glimpse we see in the trailer is from
the tail end of the film after the
losers clubs last stand with Pennywise
or maybe Eddie just dashed off to the
pharmacy to pick up a new inhaler time
will tell the settings in the trailer
for it chapter two are entirely familiar
evidently Derry hasn't put much money
for renovations over the last 27 years
one location seems to carry some major
significance though and we're not
talking about the sewer
although there's bound to be plenty of
action down there to know we're talking
about this grassy hill as you may recall
it looks like the exact same spot the
kids visited to make their blood oath in
the first film I swear if it isn't dead
and if it ever comes back
we'll come back to it's also the same
spot that both Stan and Eddie's seem to
confirm their fates by leaving the group
first in the same order they died it
surprisingly the exit order doesn't seem
to be repeated in this trailer if you
look closely it's Ritchie tozer who
trails the group instead of Eddie you
may want to avoid Chinese food for a
while
as we see in the trailer the losers Club
heads over to the Jade of the Orient
restaurant for a reunion meal just like
in the book the trailer only shows their
arrival but King fans and anyone who saw
the 1990 TV mini-series will remember
just how unappetizing things get so many
unspeakable horrors can fit into those
teeny tiny fortune cookies yes we'll
have to wait and see what ghastly
surprises it has in store the trailer
also calls back to a fixture of Kings
book and the 2017 adaptation the giant
statue of Paul Bunyan in the town park
it's there in the first film when the
losers gathered together to discuss
penny wise in the book it becomes
animated and taunts Ricci if chapter 2
brings the statue back into Ritchie's
life we don't see it in motion just yet
instead penny wise is seen floating
above it suspended by an inverted
pyramid of balloons even so the Paul
Bunyan statues importance clearly hasn't
been overlooked by the director King
fans also know that the statue really
exists in Bangor Maine and freaks out
the locals on a regular basis the first
chapter of it thankfully didn't deal
with the ritual of chud or matter een
the celestial turtle but fans know that
these otherworldly concepts will make it
into chapter 2 the trailer appears to
confirm it the losers hit the sewers to
track down penny wise and come upon a
giant spiky object we see the gang
holding hands and looking up the ceiling
or more likely something beyond the
ceiling we never get a glimpse of the
creature in the trailer but we imagine
we hope it'll be more frightening than
that thing we saw in the miniseries we
know moosh Yeti plans to bring the
interdimensional elements of it to the
big screen in chapter 2 and this is our
first look at how that might happen
scared
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite films are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]